[Music]
Purdue Pharma laid off its entire sales
team this week now only on CBS this
morning
a former Purdue sales rep claims the
drug maker downplayed the dangers of
opioids even after pleading guilty to a
felony charge of misbranding Purdue's
2007 settlement with the Justice
Department included more than 630
million dollars in fines but 24 states
and more than 400 cities and counties
are suing Purdue and its competitors
accusing them of fuelling an opioid drug
crisis that's killed more than 200,000
people Tony de copal is here with our
CBS News investigation Tony good morning
good morning big numbers and really
serious accusations Purdue makes
oxycotin you've probably heard of it too
perhaps the best-known opioid painkiller
in America in 2007 the company admitted
the falsely selling the drug as less
addictive than rivals but now a former
Purdue salesperson tells CBS News the
deceptive sales did not end there it was
always in the back of my mind that maybe
the company had not told us the whole
truth when they hired us when we
interviewed when we went through
training this is our class Carol Panera
trained for a sales job with Purdue
Pharma in 2008 so this was for the
quarter not bad
she showed us how the company's bonus
system put her in a position to make
more money by convincing doctors to
prescribe higher doses of oxycontin for
a wider range of pain
so bottom line sell as much as you can
sell as much as you can the idea being
that we're trying to expand our reach
beyond just pain doctors a year earlier
Purdue had admitted it falsely promoted
oxy cotton as less addictive by among
other means claiming the drugs
slow-release formula did not cause a
buzz or euphoria and could be used to
weed out addicts the company said the
misstatements ended in 2001 they made it
sound like it was a little bit of a
witch hunt on the government's part
but amid skyrocketing addiction rates
and overdoses related to oxycontin
panera claims the company taught a sales
tactic she now considers questionable
saying some patients might only appear
to be addicted when in fact they're just
in pain in training she was taught a
term for this pseudo addiction so the
cure for pseudo addiction you were
trained is more opioids a higher dose
yes did this concept of pseudo addiction
come with studies backing it up we had
no studies we actually we did not have
any studies that's the thing that was
kind of disturbing was that we didn't
have studies to present to the doctors
you know that sounds I know I was naive
a 2015 study published in current
addiction reports found no empirical
evidence to support pseudo addiction as
a diagnosis in a statement to CBS News
Purdue said it's confident that it's
past marketing and sales of its
prescription opioid medications have
been consistent with the information
contained in the FDA approved label but
the word pseudo addiction doesn't appear
on oxycottons label and a spokesperson
for the FDA said the labeling is not
intended as a discussion of pseudo
addiction a big loss real easy to
explain you know you just come up with a
ridiculous term like pseudo addiction
Oklahoma Attorney General Mike hunter is
one of two dozen AG's suing Purdue and
other opioid manufacturers many of the
lawsuits mentioned pseudo addiction and
that maybe it's the most disgraceful
conduct that we we've seen in the whole
pattern of disgraceful conduct so as far
as you can tell there is no scientific
basis for a pseudo addiction I reject
any notion that there's science behind
pseudo addiction hunter alleges that
Purdue and its competitors have caused a
devastating public health crisis costing
his state billions of dollars a year do
you think this is an epidemic that
begins with Purdue Pharma and oxycontin
yes that's the start of it all yes
Purdue has reportedly been in
discussions with multiple states for a
global settlement of lawsuits but hunter
says he's not interested in joining
those talks I have no confidence in that
process
I've confidence in our lawyers I have
confidence in our laws I've confidence
in a jury of Oklahomans
Carol panera who quit in 2013 says she
hopes the drug maker is held accountable
I think they misrepresented to the
public I think they misrepresented to
their salespeople and yeah I think it
was just a big charade to what end
- making money - making money
do you regret the five years you spent
with Purdue Pharma I'm gonna sum it up
and say this I think that was one of the
if not the worst career decisions of my
life in February the company said it
would stop training sales people to sell
oxycontin and this week it announced it
would stop making sales calls for the
rest of its drugs produced as its
diversifying beyond pain medications
working to develop new drugs to treat
cancer and central nervous system
disorders Thank You Carol Burnett for
speaking up pseudo addiction sounds like
a made-up word to hide very questionable
business practices do you mean
potentially a very damaging one if you
look at the sales of oxycontin they went
down in 2007-2008 and then they tripled
right after Carol took the job thank you
Tony great piece